David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-137B—the beginning of the interview with Jürgen Bassfreund, or as it’s given “I Did Not Interview the Dead,” Jorn Gastfreund. Boder.
David Boder: Munich, Germany, September the 20th, 1946. The spool is at nine minutes. The interviewee is Mr. Jürgen Bassfreund, twenty-two years old.
David Boder: [In German] Also Jürgen, wollen Sie mir sagen, wo sind Sie geboren?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich bin am 30.9.23 in Bernkastel an der Mosel geboren.
David Boder: Was wollen Sie da sagen am 30. was?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Am 30 September.
David Boder: Am 30 September—in welchem Jahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: 1923.
David Boder: Ja. Wo geboren?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Bernkastel an der Mosel, das ist bei Trier.
David Boder: Also Sie sind deutscher Angehöriger, nicht wahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja, ich bin deutscher Staatsangehöriger.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mir dann erzählen, was hat Ihnen passiert von der Zeit, hm, wo Hitler zur Macht kam? Wer waren Ihre Eltern?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Vater war Doktor der Medizin, Manfred Bassfreund.
David Boder: Wo?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Bernkastel ebenfalls.
David Boder: In Bernkastel, ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja. Und mein Vater starb schon ein Jahr bevor Hitler an die Macht kam, also im Jahre ’32.
David Boder: ’32, ja. Da waren Sie ungefähr wie alt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich war acht Jahre alt als mein Vater starb.
David Boder: Und was hat ihre Mutter getan? Was war Ihrer Mutter’s Beschäftigung?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Mutter hatte keinen Beruf.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Sie—wir lebten damals von dem Geld, hm, was mein Vater eben verdient hat und von der Hinterlassenschaft, nicht. Und im Jahr ’33 dann zogen wir nach Trier.
David Boder: Trier?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja. Das ist 40 Kilometer von Bernkastel entfernt.
David Boder: Bernkastel neben welcher großen Stadt ist es?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Bernkastel ist in der Nähe von Trier.
David Boder: Und Trier ist in der Nähe von was?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und Trier gehört eigentlich zu der Reg..., zu, hm, das ist im Rheinland...gehört zu dem Regierungsbezirk Koblenz.
David Boder: Ist das jetzt in der amerikanischen oder französischen Zone.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das ist in der französischen Besatzungszone.
David Boder: Und das war also ganz nahe zu Frankreich?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Sehr nah zu Luxemburg vor allen Dingen.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mir dann, Jürgen, wie ist es Ihnen gegangen durch die Hitlerzeit bevor dem Krieg?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also ich bin damals als einziger Jude auf das Gymnasium gekommen nach Trier. Und damals war’s schon so, dass ein gewisser militaristischer Drill—eben von der Lehrerschaft aus—auf die Schüler, hm, ausgeübt wurde, nicht. Es war so, dass wenn der Lehrer morgens in die Tür reinkam, da grüßte er die Schüler mit „Heil Hitler” und die Schüler mussten ebenfalls „Heil Hitler” grüßen. Selbstverständlich habe ich das als Jude nicht getan.
David Boder: Sie haben es nicht tun dürfen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich habe es nicht tun dürfen und auch nicht getan.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit selbstverständlich? Wie alt waren Sie denn?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich war damals acht Jahre, aber ich wusste schon damals von meinem Vater her, der damals selbst in den Orten...also als Hitler an die Macht kam, schon sehr viel Versammlungen in Lokalen hat aufheben lassen, wie man den Leuten angedroht hat, dass er eben den Juden sagen würde, dass sie nicht mehr dort etwas verkaufen sollten, die Gegend lebt dort meistens vom Weinhandel, nicht,...
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . und sehr viele auch dadurch beeinflusst waren, und auch die die Versammlungen haben nicht stattfinden lassen. Zur damaligen Zeit war das noch möglich, während das ja nach drei und dreißig nicht mehr möglich war.
David Boder: Warum haben sie die Versammlungen nicht stattfinden lassen? Welche Versammlungen haben sie gemacht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also diese Naziversammlungen, diese Wahlpropagandareden.
David Boder: Und ja, die haben die anderen nicht stattfinden lasen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, auf Grund dessen, dass mein Vater gesagt hatte, weil dort die Leute alle vom Weinhandel lebten,...
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . da würden die Juden sehr viel dort an diese Leute verkauften, an diese Wirtschaften, hat er gesagt, dass er dann den ... den Leuten das sagen wird, dass sie dort nicht mehr verkaufen sollten, wenn sie dort irgendwie einen nazistischen Einfluss, hm, oder Propaganda betreiben würden.
David Boder: Und nach ’33 sagten Sie, war das nicht mehr möglich?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nach ’33 war es nicht mehr möglich.
David Boder: Nicht möglich, warum?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Denn es wusste jeder, dass wenn man irgendwie etwas sagte, dass man sofort ins Konzentrationslager kam oder irgendwie in Haft. Und jeder war sehr ängstlich und man, man durfte eben nicht auffallen.
David Boder: Ja. Und Ihr Vater starb in welchem Jahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Im Jahr ’32. Da starb mein Vater, ja.
David Boder: Hm. Also Sie kamen nach Trier. Warum wurden Sie als einziger Jude aufgenommen ins Gymnasium?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, es war damals...damals bestand ein gewisser Prozentsatz Juden, die noch ans Gymnasium durften. Und ich weiß nicht, wie hoch der Prozentsatz war, jedenfalls war das auf die drei Schulen so verteilt, dass ich gerade noch mit hinein durfte.
David Boder: Haben Sie ein Examen machen müssen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Bitte? Nein, nein, ich...das war eben nachdem die vier Grundschuljahre beendet waren, war es so bei uns, dass man dann auf die höhere Schule kam, nicht, also aufs Gymnasium. Und da meine Mutter mich Arzt werden lassen wollte, musste ich eine humanistische Bildung haben, also Latein und—nicht—wie das so ist. Aber es war schon damals sehr schlimm, man wurde sehr angefeindet unter den Schülern, weil sie, hm, versuchten möglichst, hm,...sehr viel antisemitische Propaganda zu machen und haben einem natürlich das Leben sehr erschwert. Und als ich das eine Jahr hatte, wollte ich schon gar nicht mehr zur Schule gehen und habe meine Mutter gebeten, sie soll mich auf eine...auf eine jüdische Schule gehen lassen. Und meine Mutter zog damals mir zu Liebe nach Köln. Dort war noch ein jüdisches Realgymnasium. Und ich hab dann...ich bin dann von übergesiedelt nach Köln und bin dort auf die Schule gegangen.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir mal, war das Realgymnasium in Köln...ein jüdisches Gymnasium von bevor dort?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Bitte?
David Boder: War das Gymnasium schon bevor Hitler ein jüdisches Gymnasium dort?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja, das war schon, das war schon vor Hitlers Zeit ein jüdisches Gymnasium.
David Boder: Und man hat das bestehen lassen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ha, man hat das vorläufig noch bestehen lassen. Wie lange es bestanden hat, weiß ich allerdings nicht mehr.
David Boder: Und also wie lange waren Sie dort in Köln auf dem Gymnasium?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Köln auf diesem Gymnasium war ich bis zum Jahre 1936.
David Boder: Ja. Also wie viele Klassen haben Sie da durch gemacht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also ich war, ich ging bis zur Quarta damals und dann kam ich nach Coburg in ein jüdisches Internat.
David Boder: Warum sind Sie von Köln weggegangen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Weil ich, hm, in Köln...also in Köln war es so, man lernte nur Französisch und Englisch und ich hätte gerne noch Latein gelernt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und diese Möglichkeit bestand damals nicht und außerdem war es auch so, dass man schon in...dass es...also es wurde einem in einem jüdischen Internat natürlich mehr geboten. Es war dort ein jüdisches Leben, das bestand, nicht, und es war dort eben besser.
David Boder: Wie viele Kinder haben Ihre Eltern gehabt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Meine Mutter hatte, also...außer mir habe ich noch eine Schwester, die in England lebt. Sie kam kurz vor dem Krieg im Jahre ’39 nach England.
David Boder: Nun...und, hm...aber damals war Ihr Schwester noch hier?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Damals war meine Schwester noch hier, jawohl.
David Boder: Und wo ist sie zur Schule gegangen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Schwester ging ebenfalls dort in diese Schule, das war...für die Mädchen...
David Boder: Was das das Internat?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, in diese Tagesschule in Köln, das war eine gemischte Schule für Mädchen und Knaben.
David Boder: Ja und nachher?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und nachher ging meine Schwester in den Haushalt.
David Boder: Was heißt ein Haushalt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In eine Haushaltungsschule—in eine jüdische.
David Boder: In eine jüdische Haushaltungsschule?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Also weiter. Und haben Sie dann durch das Internat das Gymnasium beendet, haben Sie Ihre Matura gemacht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, ich konnte die Matura damals nicht mehr machen...
David Boder: Hm, hm.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . denn damals war es, war es schon sehr schwer und meine Mutter wollte mich, hm, weil sie sehr ängstlich war, weil Coburg bekannt war für sehr antisemitische Stimmung, hat mich meine Mutter wieder zurückgeholt.
David Boder: War das Coburg-Gotha?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das ist dieses Coburg, das bekannt war durch diesen Hitlerputsch, glaube ich.
David Boder: Was?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Durch diesen Hitler Putsch damals in Coburg.
David Boder: War das neben München?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, da liegt also nicht sehr weit von Eisenach, zwischen...das ist Franken—zwischen Nürnberg und Eisenach liegt das.
David Boder: Ja, weiter. Also wie ist es Ihnen dort weiter gegangen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also, ich bin dann von dieser Schule—ich bin—ich war damals in der Untertertia—bin ich fortgekommen und wir sind damals nach Berlin gezogen und ich habe dann eine Handwerkerschule besucht.
David Boder: Eine jüdische Handwerkerschule?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Eine jüdische Handwerkerschule, jawohl. Es war damals...
David Boder: Wer hat diese Handwerkerschule veranstaltet?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Diese Handwerkerschule wurde damals von der jüdischen Gemeinde in Berlin veranstaltet.
David Boder: Und weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dann besuchte ich anschließend, weil ich immer sehr großes Interesse an Fotographie hatte, hab ich einen fotographischen Kurs gleich anschließend mitgenommen, der ebenfalls von der jüdischen Gemeinde in Berlin veranstaltet wurde. Und wurde dann im Jahre 1941 einfach aus dieser Schule herausgenommen und man zwang mich, in einer Fabrik zu arbeiten. Das war damals schon dieser Kriegseinsatz, an dem die Juden auch, hm, zu dem die Juden hin mussten. Und ich bin damals in eine Fabrik gekommen und habe dort Leder transportieren müssen und meine Mutter war in derselben Fabrik und hat dort auch gearbeitet und Leder ausgestanzt. Also damals gab es das überhaupt nicht, dass man irgendwie von der Arbeit hätte fernbleiben können. Es war so, dass es eben eine Pflicht war und wenn man gefehlt hat, wurde es als Sabotage betrachtet, hm, und man wurde eben dementsprechend verhaftet oder...
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . wie die meisten, man ist plötzlich verschwunden, nicht.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, wo ist dann Ihre Schwester geblieben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Meine...
David Boder: War sie auch in der Fabrik?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, meine Schwester kam schon im Jahre ’39 glücklicherweise noch nach England, dank der Initiative meiner Mutter, die an ein Kinderkrankenhaus nach Newcastle upon Tyne geschrieben hatte und meine Schwester konnte dort als baby nurse, hm,...
David Boder: Arbeiten.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . arbeiten.
David Boder: Ist Ihre Schwester älter?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Schwester ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
David Boder: Ist sie jetzt in England auch?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Meine Schwester ist immer noch in England, jawohl.
David Boder: Und wo ist Ihre Mutter?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Meine Mutter, hm,...lebt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Wir wurden damals im Jahre 1943, das war am sieben und 27 Februar plötzlich von der Arbeit weg genommen. Ich arbeitete damals auf der Bahn und die Leibstandarte Adolf Hitler trieb uns in Autos hinein und wir wurden zu einem Sammellager gefahren.
David Boder: Wir kommen danach weg—später. Also Sie haben beide in einer Fabrik gearbeitet? In welchem Jahre an?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das war vom Jahre ’41 ab.
David Boder: Also vom Jahre ’41 da fingen Sie und Ihre Mutter an in einer Fabrik zusammen zu arbeiten?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das heißt wir mussten.
David Boder: Sie mussten! Hat man Sie für die Arbeit bezahlt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, natürlich einen ganz geringen Lohn. Die Frauen erhielten 40 Pfennige die Stunde und ich war damals noch Jugendlicher—ich bekam, hm, 43 oder 44 Pfennige.
David Boder: Und Sie haben zu Hause gelebt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich habe zu Hause noch gelebt, ja.
David Boder: Ja, Sie hatten einen Wohnung, wie groß war die Wohnung?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, unsere Wohnung waren drei Zimmer.
David Boder: Ah, hm.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Drei Zimmer und Küche.
David Boder: Nun weiter, also was war nachher?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also nachher spitzte sich die Lager immer mehr zu. Es war schon.... dann kam diese Sache mit dem Judenstern auf, nicht. Und es war schon gefährlich, über die Strasse zu gehen. Naziagenten, Gestapoagenten liefen herum und verhafteten Juden auf der Strasse. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an einen Freund von mir, der mit mir in der Fabrik arbeitete. Er wurde...sein Vater wurde abends von Polizei verhaftet. Und es wurde gesagt, dass in Berlin ein Attentat auf eine Naziausstellung verübt worden ist und, hm, diese Juden—es waren, glaub ich, 500 soweit ich noch mich erinnern kann, wurden dann in der SS-Kaserne in Lichterfelde erschossen. Und die Angehörigen dieser Leute wurden zwangsverschleppt. Also damals sagte man „evakuiert”. Also, später hat man erst gewusst, was es eigentlich ist.
David Boder: Hat man damals das nicht gewusst?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass selbst die jüdische Gemeinde das nicht gewusst hat. Denn noch als ich, als ich verhaftet wurde, gab man uns noch Seife und Kleidungsstücke mit, weil wir von der Arbeit ja nichts mit hatten, außer den, außer diesen Sachen, die wir anhatten. Hat uns die jüdischen Gemeinde selbst noch Sachen gegeben und ich nehme an, wenn sie gewusst hätte, wo wir hinkommen, hätte sie das selbstverständlich nicht getan.
David Boder: Nun ja, vielleicht...Wir können das nicht diskutieren. Aber die jüdische Gemeinde hat gewusst also...hat Ihnen Sachen mitgegeben. Und warum hat man gerade Sie herausgeholt von der Arbeit oder. . .?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Man hat alle geholt...das war...
David Boder: Alle?
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . das war eine Großaktion. In Berlin hat man sämtliche Juden, die mit mir arbeiteten, es waren ungefähr 50 Mann auf unserem Bahnhof, hat man 40 verhaftet, wir wussten selbst nicht, wie uns geschah. Plötzlich waren wir umringt von der Leibstandarte, und wurden dann mit Füßen getreten und in Autos verladen.
David Boder: Ja, nun und wohin wurden Sie dann geschickt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wir wurden in ein Sammellager gebracht, das...das früher einmal, also, ein Gebäude der jüdischen Gemeinde war.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und dort lagen Matratzen und wir mussten dort drei, vier Tage von Polizei und SS bewacht, mussten wir dort zu bringen. Und dann kamen wieder Autos und wieder wurden wir von der Leibstandarte zu einem ganz entlegenen Bahnhof in Berlin gebracht und wurden dort einwagoniert und...und die Wagons wurden verschlossen. Und vorher wurde uns noch gesagt, dass wenn je...wenn ein Mensch aus dem Wagon flüchten würde, dass dann der ganze Wagon erschossen wird.
David Boder: Nun...hat Ihre Mutter gewusst, dass Sie verhaftet worden sind?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein,...ich weiß es nicht. Ich selbst wusste nicht, dass meine Mutter verhaftet wurde, aber...
David Boder: Nein, hat ihre Mutter gewusst, dass Sie verhaftet worden sind?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Na, ich weiß es nicht, weil ich meine Mutter nicht mehr gesehen habe seit diesem Zeitpunkt.
David Boder: Seit diesem Zeitpunkt haben Sie Ihre Mutter nicht mehr gesehen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein.
David Boder: Also, nun wollen wir mal sehen, wohin wurden Sie dann geschickt von diesem abgelegenen Bahnhof? Wie heißt der Bahnhof?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Der Bahnhof ist der Verladebahnhof Putlitzstrasse und zu dieser Zeit damals wurden gefangene Russen meistens dort ausgeladen, also das war ein ganz entlegener Bahnhof in Berlin, er lag gegenüber von einer großen Rüstungsfabrik, Thyssen [?].
David Boder: Ja. Nun und wohin...wie wurden Sie dann in diese Wagen eingeladen - vergessen Sie das. Wie viele Personen wurden Sie in einen Wagen eingeladen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wir waren damals ungefähr 50 Personen in einem Wagen. Und Frauen und Männer und Kinder durcheinander. Und die Türen wurden zugemacht. Und wir sind weggefahren und sind nachmittags um fünf abgefahren und waren am anderen Abend um halb elf in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Hat man ihnen zu essen gegeben auf dem Weg?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Die jüdische Gemeinde hat uns noch Brote mit gegeben, jawohl, und...
David Boder: Die jüdische Gemeinde hat gewusst, dass sie weggeschickt werden?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, selbstverständlich hat die jüdische Gemeinde das gewusst.
David Boder: Ja, wieso ist das so selbstverständlich?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wir haben es ja auch gewusst. In der Minute, wo wir auf die Bahn gesetzt wurden, wussten wir, dass wir wegkommen. Nur wir wussten nicht, wohin wir kommen.
David Boder: Und so hat die jüdische Gemeinde Ihnen zu essen mitgegeben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat sie Ihnen gegeben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also wir bekamen damals, hm, sechs Scheiben Brot mit Margarine und Käse. Weiß ich noch.
David Boder: Das war alles?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie getrunken?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wir bekamen, in jeden Wagon wurde eine Kanne mit Wasser gestellt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also so ein großes Gefäß.
David Boder: Ja. Und die Wagons wurden zugeschlossen. Was für Wagons waren die?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Es waren diese gewöhnlichen Wagons, in denen man die Waren transportiert, also diese...
David Boder: Das sind Frachtwagons.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Frachtwagons, ja.
David Boder: Hatten Sie eine Toilette dort gehabt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, eine Toilette hatten wir nicht und das wurde sogar im Laufe des Tages war das eine sehr schlimme Angelegenheit, weil doch sehr viele Leute in der Aufregung auf Toilette mussten und es war doch keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie etwas zu machen. Wir hatten eine Schüssel im Wagon und es war natürlich unangenehm, die Türen waren zu und die Luft wurde schlecht.
David Boder: Ja. Und da waren Frauen und Kinder und Männer alle zusammen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, Frauen und Kinder und Männer alles durcheinander.
David Boder: Sie sagten, sie waren 50 auf der Station. Waren das alle Männer, die 50 Leute in Ihrer Fabrik, waren das alle Männer, die dort verhaftet wurden?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, es wurden verschiedene, es waren in den Wagons—also in diesen Wagons waren verschiedene, also manchmal die Frauen noch und die Männer mussten die Adressen von den Frauen sagen, weil sie nicht wussten, wo sie hingehen und man hat die Frauen dann zu Hause durch Polizei abholen lassen. Und ich hab noch etwas vergessen, was ich für sehr wichtig erachte. Bevor wir abtransportiert wurden, mussten wir unterschreiben, dass wir wegen staatspolitischer und feindlicher Umtriebe Deutschland verlassen müssen.
David Boder: Aha. Das mussten Sie unterschreiben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das mussten wir unterschreiben.
David Boder: Ihre Mutter hat ja mit Ihnen auf der Fabrik gearbeitet.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, aber nachher nicht mehr. Meine Mutter...ich wurde dann zur Bahn geschickt und...
David Boder: Ja, aber sagen Sie...ach—Sie wurden zur Bahn geschickt!
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich wurde zur Bahn in die Arbeit geschickt und meine Mutter war noch in der Fabrik.
David Boder: Darum, wenn man Sie genommen hat, hat man noch ihre Mutter in der Fabrik nicht genommen.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, doch. An diesem Tag machte man eine Aktion und sämtliche arbeitenden Leute wurden weggenommen. Ich glaube, das war in ganz Berlin verschieden.
David Boder: Also nun, Sie kamen wohin dann, nach Auschwitz?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat dort passiert?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also in Auschwitz wurden wir ausgeladen aus diesen Wagons und man...
David Boder: War das ein ganzer Zug?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, es war ein ganzer Zug, es waren 1000 Menschen.
David Boder: Ja, wieso wissen Sie die Zahl?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, also es war durchgesickert, dass jeder Transport 1000 Menschen betragen hat. Und der ungefähren Schätzung nach, also als die Leute, die vor den Wagons standen, ist es auch anzunehmen, dass es 1000 Menschen waren.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und wir wurden aus diesen Wagons herausgetrieben mit, hm, von SS- Leuten, die mit Spazierstöcken außer ihren Gewehren bewaffnet waren und man fing an, auf uns einzuschlagen und als nun die Frauen auf die eine Seite mussten und die Männer auf die andere und...also wir getrennt wurden, erhob sich ein großes Geschrei und es war sehr schlimm. Es hörte sich an—also, man kann es gar nicht wiedergeben. Ich werde dieses Schreien nie vergessen können.
David Boder: Warum hat das Geschrei angefangen? Die Frauen waren ja nicht mit den Männern verheiratet.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Doch—selbstverständlich waren sehr viele Ehepaare darunter. Und man hat die Kinder den...es war nun so, dass verschiedentlich die Männer die Kinder auf dem Arm hatten, und die Frauen mussten die Kinder nehmen. Nun fanden die Männer mannchmal in der dunklen Nacht und bei den vielen Menschen die Frauen nicht und dadurch war ein großes Geschrei. Vielleicht ahnten auch die Leute schon, was...was ihnen passieren würde.
David Boder: Und was hat Ihnen passiert?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also ich wurde zu den Männern gestellt und ein SS-Mann fragte mich, ob ich gesund sei. Darauf hin sagte ich ‚ja’, und dann sagte er, ich muss auf die andere Seite gehen. Und auf der anderen Seite standen alte und schwache Männer und meistens Frauen mit Kindern und ältere...ältere Personen. Und wir haben später erst erfahren, dass dort, dass diese Frauen und diese älteren Männer zur Vergasung gebracht würden. Mir selbst fiel auf, als ich dort ankam...
David Boder: Sind Sie auf die andere Seite gekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Bitte?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich kam auf die rechte Seite und ich wusste selbst damals noch nicht, was das bedeuten sollte. Jedenfalls mussten wir warten. Ich sah...ich wollte mich orientieren und sah in der Ferne überall Türme mit Posten besetzt, mit SS-Posten mit Maschinengewehr und sah in der Ferne ein sehr großes Feuer brennen. Ich wusste damals noch nicht, was es war und erfuhr erst später, dass das die großen Krematorien von Auschwitz sind, wo diese ganzen Leute vergast und verbrannt wurden.
David Boder: Ja, also sind Sie als Schwächling auf die andere Seite rüber gegangen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, ich kam auf die Seite der Leute, die arbeitsfähig sind.
David Boder: Aber der SS Mann hat ja gesagt, dass Sie schwach sind.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, er fragte mich, ob ich gesund bin und daraufhin sagte ich ‚ja’ und dann musste ich auf die rechte Seite zu den arbeitenden Leuten gehen. Und dann wurden wir auf große Lastwagen verladen und wurden nach Buna gebracht. Also Buna, das ist ein Nebenkonzentrationslager von Auschwitz selbst, das liegt ungefähr sechs, sieben Kilometer von Auschwitz entfernt. Und damals plante dort die I. G. Farben, eine synthetische Gummi- und Benzinfabrik zu errichten.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und wir wurden damals zu diesen Arbeiten genommen. Also zuerst, als ich ankam, es war Nacht, wurden wir wieder geschlagen und dann mussten wir stehen bis morgens um fünf Uhr. Dann wurden wir in einen neuen...
David Boder: Warum wurden Sie geschlagen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, warum, das...das wussten die meisten Leute selbst nicht. Das war ein sogenannter Lagerältester, das war der erste Häftling des Lagers und das war ein Berufsverbrecher...
David Boder: War er ein Jude?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, es war kein Jude. Es war ein Berufsverbrecher und er schlug auf die Leute ein. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass zum Beispiel, dass der Vater eines meiner Kollegen damals von ihm an einen...an einen Ofen gedrückt wurde, an eine Heizung, und dass er sich ein ganzes Loch aus dem Bein rausgebrannt hat.
David Boder: Ach, war die Heizung heiß?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: In welchem Monat des Jahres war es?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das war im Februar.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dann kamen wir in den Waschraum. Und dort mussten wir uns erst eiskalt baden und dann bekamen wir die Haare abgeschnitten.
David Boder: Wer hat das gemacht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das mussten Häftlinge machen.
David Boder: Und dann haben sie die Haare abgeschnitten?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also mit einer Rasiermaschine—ganz kurz, nicht.
David Boder: Ja, auf dem ganzen Körper?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, auf dem ganzen Körper, es war eine sogenannte ‚Entlausung’, wie man dazu sagte. Also es wurden die Haare abgeschnitten, wir wurden mit Petroleum eingerieben und mussten dann kalt brausen, dann mussten wir nackt über den Hof gehen...
David Boder: Und noch einmal kalt baden, nicht wahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, danach noch mal baden und mussten dann nackt über den Hof gehen und bekamen dann ein nasses Hemd, das war wohl noch aus der Wäscherei—ganz nass—ein nasses Hemd und eine Sträflingsjacke und –hose, einen Pullover und...
David Boder: War das ein warmer Pullover?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja, es war allerdings verschieden, manchmal war es ein dünner und manchmal war es ein dicker, wie man gerade Glück hatte, nicht.
David Boder: Waren die Sachen neu?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, die Sachen waren abgetragen und es ist anzunehmen, dass war aus den früheren Transporten, wie das in Auschwitz meistens der Fall war; entweder von vergasten Leuten oder von Leuten, die also...die Sachen mussten wir ja alle an der Bahn liegen lassen, nicht, mitnehmen durften wir ja gar nichts. . .
David Boder: Und die Sachen, die Ihnen das jüdische Komitee gegeben hat?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, die mussten wir alle liegen lassen. Niemand durfte etwas mitnehmen. Es gab manche Leute, die selbstverständlich nicht überraschend wegkamen, das heißt, die zu Hause geholt wurden, die durften noch Koffer mitnehmen, aber sie haben die Sachen selbstverständlich nie mehr gesehen, sondern die Sachen wurden beschlagnahmt und sie mussten alles stehen und liegen lassen. Und wer irgendetwas in der Hand hatte, wurde noch geschlagen und so, also es war besser, alles schnell weg zu werfen, bevor irgendwie ein SS-Mann irgendwie etwas gesehen hat.
David Boder: Haben Sie Geld mit sich gehabt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, Geld hatte ich mit mir, allerdings war es nicht viel; es waren ungefähr 50 Mark. Ich hatte auch einen Ring am Finger, den hat mir sofort ein SS-Mann abgezogen.
David Boder: Hm. Nun?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Als ich dann im Lager war, mussten wir dann...uns registrieren lassen. Wir bekamen dann diese bekannte Tätowierung von Auschwitz in den Arm. Ich bekam die Nummer 106377.
David Boder: Ist das eine Eins?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das ist eine Eins, Null, hundertsechstausenddreihundertsiebenundsiebzig.
David Boder: Siebenundsiebzig, und was bedeutet das Dreieck?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dieses Dreieck wurde erst später hinein gemacht, das heißt Jude. Also die...
David Boder: Wann später...wurde das...?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das wurde drei Monate nachdem ich im Lager war, wurde das gemacht. Es war wahrscheinlich eine Vorsichtsmaßnahme, oder sie wollten genau wissen, wer Jude und wer nicht Jude ist, weil die polnischen Häftlinge und die ausländischen Arbeiter ebenfalls tätowiert wurden, wollten sie eben die Juden noch besser kennzeichnen.
David Boder: Aha und die polnischen und die ausländischen Arbeiter wurden tätowiert?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja...und wir auch und wir erhielten danach dieses Dreieck, also...um damit zu sagen, dass wir Juden sind.
David Boder: Weiter. Nun?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dann wurden wir zur Arbeit geschickt und wir...also schon am Morgen versuchten viele, Selbstmord zu begehen. Sie liefen aus der Reihe der Posten raus und wurden dann eben erschossen, net. Dann schrieb man die Nummer auf den Bauch mit einem Tintenstift und die Leute wurden liegen gelassen und wurden dann später mit einem Wagen abgeholt...mit einem Auto wurden sie abgeholt.
David Boder: Welche Nummer schrieb man auf den Bauch?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Die Nummer, die man auf dem Arm hatte, schrieben sie noch mal auf den Bauch...
David Boder: Mit einem Tintenstift?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mit einem Tintenstift, ja. Und dann wurden die Leute auf Autos verladen und zum Krematorium gebracht.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und damals wurde ich in ein Kommando gesteckt, das war Zementtragen. Und es war damals, es war so, wir mussten so arbeiten, dass wir...wir durften uns keine Minute ausruhen und selbst wenn einem die Hose rutschte, weil es natürlich selbstverständlich alles verschiedene Hosen waren. Einer hatte eine Hose, die sehr gross war und ein anderer hatte wieder, die zu eng war. Also wir konnten noch nicht einmal die Hosen raufziehen und da stand ein Dings, ein Capo dabei und der schlug uns immer mit einer Eisenstange, wenn wir uns irgendwie ausruhen wollten oder...
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . oder einmal Pause machen wollten. Und dann mittags um zwölf Uhr bekamen wir dann eine Suppe, das war Wasser mit so einem...mit Blättern so eine...es war unidentifizierbar, was es war und dann mussten wir wieder...diese Suppe mussten wir im Stehen essen. Und wir wurden dann—direkt nachdem wir, direkt nachdem wir diese Suppe gegessen hatten, war schon der Mittag vorbei, weil es ja ein großes Kommando war. Es waren vielleicht 800 Menschen in diesem Kommando und wir mussten wieder weiter arbeiten und...
David Boder: Und das war in welchem Jahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das war im Jahr ’43 im Februar.
David Boder: Nun...und von Auschwitz wohin sind Sie gekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Von Auschwitz...ich war erst in diesem Nebenlager und kam dann im Juni nach Auschwitz selbst.
David Boder: In ’43?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, im Juni ’43 kam ich in das Hauptlager von Auschwitz.
David Boder: Nun?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und in diesem Hauptlager von Auschwitz war es...insofern war man noch näher und an dieser ganzen Sache dran, man wusste genau was passiert. Man sah von dort auch schon die Krematorien auf den Arbeitsstellen und man hörte auch von diesen Transporten, während man auf diesem Nebenlager weniger wusste. Es wurden Leute weggefahren und man sagte, sie kommen in ein anderes Lager, aber damals wusste man noch nicht so genau. Erst später in Auschwitz habe ich dann erst kennengelernt, wie diese ganzen Sachen vor sich gehen. Also es wurden zum Beispiel Leute die krank waren, die im Krankenrevier lagen, wurden aufgeschrieben—angeblich, weil sie schlecht aussehen, damit sie mehr Brot bekämen. Aber es war nicht so. Am anderen Tag wurden sie auf Autos geladen und wurden dort in die Gasanstalt gefahren, nicht, und wurden dann vergast und am anderen Tag waren die Kleider von diesen Leuten, die die getragen haben, schon wieder in der Wäscherei zum Waschen. Ich hab auf diese Art selbst einmal einen Anzug von einem Freund von mir, der mit mir aus Berlin kam, selbst wieder erkannt, weil die Nummer noch oben war.
David Boder: Ah, hm. Nun? Also wohin sind Sie nach Buna gegangen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Von Buna kam ich dann nach Auschwitz, in das Hauptlager. Wir wurden damals auf, auf...mit einem Auto hingefahren. Es waren sieben Menschen im Ganzen und zwar aus dem einfachen Grund, weil man behauptete ich sei zu schwach, deshalb hat man mich nach Auschwitz geschickt. Wir kamen damals in den sogenannten Krankenbau und dort wurde uns schon gesagt, dass wir uns möglichst schnell...dass wir möglichst schnell wieder fort gehen sollten, damit wir nicht auch in diese Vergasungstransporte kamen, die damals zu meiner Zeit fast vierzehntäglich, manchmal auch anders, manchmal auch...
David Boder: Noch einmal, man hat gesagt, dass sie was tun sollten?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich soll mich schnell wieder zur Arbeit melden, damit ich der Vergasung entgehe.
David Boder: Nun und weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und das habe ich auch dann getan. Ich habe ihnen sofort gesagt, dass ich mich wieder gut fühle und...und ich möchte wieder arbeiten. Und daraufhin hat man mich dann aus diesem Krankenbau entlassen und ich kam dann auf eine Arbeitsstelle in einer Tischlerei. Und das war eine Tischlerei von dort...die lag zwischen Auschwitz und Birkenau. Und in diesem Birkenau—das war dieses Lager, wo auch diese Krematorien waren. Und ich hab damals in der ersten Zeit, wir haben nachts gearbeitet, und nachts um zwölf Uhr ist mein Freund und ich immer raufgegangen in diesem hohen Gebäude und wir haben von oben gesehen dann, dass die...dass diese Brände und...weil die Krematorien damals nicht ausgereicht haben...
David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 20th, 1946 in a transient camp of UNRRA in the Funkenkaserne. We continue with the interview of Jürgen Bassfreund, which we started on Spool 137, interrupted by the songs of the Mennonites, and now from...and now from eighteen minutes of Spool 138 we begin again.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Jürgen, Sie haben erst in Bauarbeit getan, nicht wahr? Und dann wurden Sie zu einer Fischerei versetzt, hm?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Also Sie waren einerseits schwach und dann hatten Sie Angst gehabt, dass man Ihrer Schwäche wegen, Sie möglichst, hm, umbringt und so sind Sie zurück zur Arbeit gegangen.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und ich habe dann im September 1943, das war wohl zu der Zeit, als Italien kapitulierte, also als das faschistische System zusammenstürzte, da war natürlich die Wut sehr gross unter den Nazis und man hat sofort einen großen Vergasungstransport zusammengestellt und zu diesem Transport sollte ich auch kommen. Ich hab mich durch einen Trick da herausgerettet, und zwar sollte der Transport nach dem täglichen Appell, der abends stattfand, und an dem immer abgezählt wurde, also nach der Arbeit, ob Leute weg gekommen sind, abhanden gekommen sind oder geflüchtet sind. Und diese, diese Rapporte, wie man das im Konzentrationslager nannte, sind dem Obersturmführer gemeldet worden, dem Lagerkommandanten, dann bin ich einfach—anstatt zur Vergasung, zu der ich schon aufgeschrieben war—zur Arbeit gegangen.
David Boder: Das war in der Nacht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja. Ich habe nachts gearbeitet in dieser Wäscherei, dort wurde Nachtschicht und Tagschicht gearbeitet.
David Boder: Also wieso—wofür wurden Sie aufgeschrieben? Was hat man Ihnen gesagt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also man hat zu mir gesagt, es wird ein Transport zusammengestellt für schwache Leute in ein anderes Lager, wo leichte Arbeit ist. Aber das hat nicht gestimmt, also an meinem Bett, wir hatten diese dreistöckigen Betten, an meinem Bett war mit Kreide ein Kreuz gemacht—zur Erkennung, net, dass ich...dass ich in diesem Bett liege und dass ich für diesen Transport bestimmt war. Und ich hab mich dadurch gerettet, dass ich nachts zur Arbeit ging. Und als ich morgens wieder ins Lager kam, da war dieser ganze Transport schon längst vergast und die Kleider waren schon wieder zurück zum Waschen, wie das immer üblich war. Und ich hab mich dadurch aus diesem Transport. Also ich habe dadurch mir das Leben gerettet, denn sonst wäre ich ja auch zu diesem Transport gekommen.
David Boder: Haben die denn bei der Arbeit nicht gewusst, dass Sie nicht mehr dort hingehören?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Na, selbstverständlich, man hat es gewusst, aber ich hab es im Einvernehmen mit dem Capo hab ich das gemacht.
David Boder: Also der Capo hat es gewusst?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, der Capo hat davon gewusst, ja. Und ich hab dann...
David Boder: War der Capo ein Jude?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, der Capo war kein Jude.
David Boder: Was war er?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Der Capo war ein Deutscher, und war sogar ein, ein Berufsverbrecher...
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . aber er hatte manchmal sehr gute Seiten an sich, und...
David Boder: Haben Sie ihm etwas dafür gegeben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, ich hab ihm nichts dafür gegeben. Ich hätte ihm auch nichts geben können, weil ich gar nicht dazu in der Lage war, weil ich im Lager immer zu der Unterschicht gehört habe, es gab nämlich im Lager, genau wie draußen auch verschiedene Schichten. Es gab die Capos und die Blockälteste, die alles im Überfluss hatten, nicht, und dadurch, dass sie eben...dass sie uns schikanierten und uns der SS auslieferten, wie das in vielen Fällen passiert ist und andere wieder, das waren die Blockschreiber und so, die mit ihnen unter einer Decke waren, die hatten natürlich ein gutes Leben. Und dann gab es eben wieder eine Arbeiterschicht, zu der wir gehörten, die effektiv nur von dem gelebt haben, was sie bekommen haben und das war dieses Stück Brot, diese zwei Scheiben trockenes Brot und die Suppe. Das war alles.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nun wollte ich eigentlich erzählen, wie wir nachher, als schon die russischen Armeen Auschwitz sich näherten, von Auschwitz nach Dachau transportiert wurden. Das ist insofern sehr interessant, weil es eigentlich die größte Strapaze von allen war, die wir im Lager mitgemacht hatten. Wir waren sehr viel schon gewöhnt, aber das war das Letzte, wo die meisten Menschen wahrscheinlich haben ihr Leben lassen müssen.
David Boder: Von wo ging der Transport—von Auschwitz nach Dachau?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Von Auschwitz nach Dachau, ja.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie uns bitte über diese Reise ausführlich, ganz ausführlich erzählen.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ganz ausführlich erzählen. Also am 18. Januar sahen wir nachts schon...
David Boder: Welches Jahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: 1945. Da sahen wir schon die Leuchtkugeln von der Front aufsteigen, also die Front war nicht weit von uns. Also Krakau war von uns 60 Kilometer entfernt und es waren schon Gerüchte durchgesickert, dass in Krakau schon die Russen sind. Nun wurden wir plötzlich wahllos—wurde alles auf Transport geschickt, morgens ging schon ein Transport. Wir mussten noch den Tag über arbeiten und als wir abends ins Lager kamen, waren wir die letzten, die auf Transport gingen. Es war an dem Tag sehr kalt und wir bekamen etwas Verpflegung mit und wurden dann auf den Marsch geschickt. Also wir sind erst stundenlang durch die Nacht marschiert. Und zwar—wir sind...
David Boder: Das war im Januar?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja. Und kamen dann nach Pleß. Unterwegs sind furchtbar viele Menschen erschossen worden, die nicht mehr weiter konnten und die schlapp gemacht haben; also jeder, der auf der Strecke liegen blieb, wurde erschossen, ob das Frauen oder Männer waren, das spielte keine Rolle. Wir sind nämlich mit dem Frauenlager zur gleichen Zeit weggegangen und trafen die Frauen vor Pleß und sahen auch unterwegs sehr viel Leichen von Frauen auf der Erde liegen, nicht. Und wir sind nachts marschiert, tagsüber mussten wir rasten, damit die Bevölkerung nicht gesehen hat, wie wir durchgeführt werden. Und abends, wenn es dunkel war, sind wir wieder weitermarschiert.
David Boder: Im Januar?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das war im Januar.
David Boder: War da Schnee?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, es war Schnee und es war sehr kalt. Es war direkt ein Schneesturm, man konnte die Augen gar nicht aufmachen.
David Boder: Und was für eine Kleidung hatten Sie?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wir hatten nichts weiter als unsere Anzüge, als unsere Sträflingsanzüge. Und teilweise hatten wir sehr schlechte Schuhe. Also es war so: die erst gegangen sind, haben sich schon bessere Sachen wegnehmen können, nicht, aber als wir mit dem letzten Transport gingen, war nur schon alles, was gerade noch so übrig war. Das wurde uns dann gegeben, das heißt, man konnte es sich nehmen. Es war schon keine Ordnung mehr im Lager, die SS war schon...also schon auf dem Abmarsch. Alles wurde evakuiert. Die Pferdeställe der SS mit den sehr wertvollen Reitpferden und alles...das war alles schon unterwegs. Und wir sind dann marschiert über Pleß und kamen an einen kleinen Ort in Schlesien, der hieß Löslau und dort wurden wir einwagoniert und fuhren dann nach Groß-Rosen, das auch ein sehr berüchtigtes Konzentrationslager war, wo besonders viele Berufsverbrecher waren. Also dort wurden wir zu...zu...
David Boder: Welche Stadt in der Nähe ist Groß-Rosen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Groß-Rosen, das dürfte in der Nähe von Breslau sein, genau weiß ich es nicht, aber so in der Gegend muss es sein. Und wir sind dann dort in dieses Lager hereingekommen und dort steckte man uns in Baracken hinein. Es war eine Unmenge Menschen, man konnte noch nicht mal nachts schlafen. Wir haben alle aufrecht gesessen—also es war einer an dem anderen. Und wenn man irgendwie ein bisschen sich bewegt oder bisschen rumgegangen ist, war immer schon ein Berufsverbrecher da mit einem großen Holzknüppel und der hat dann wahllos in die Menge hinein geschlagen. Also, es war furchtbar. Und als plötzlich dann am zweiten Tag gesagt wurde, es ging wieder einen Transport, da habe ich mich schnell freiwillig gemeldet, weil ich mir gedacht habe, schlimmer kann es schon gar nicht mehr kommen wie in diesem Lager. Zum Essen bekamen wir überhaupt sehr wenig, eine ganz dünne Wassersuppe, da waren manchmal noch nicht mal mehr Kohlrüben drin, wie es sonst üblich war, und ein Stück Brot. Dann schickte man uns, sagte man uns, also das ist durchgesickert, dass dieser Transport nach Dachau geht. Also wir sind angetreten und bekamen noch einen Teller Suppe und dann sind wir von Begleitung von SS zur Bahn gegangen—also an die Station—und wurden dort einwagoniert. Es waren teilweise offene und teilweise geschlossene Wagons. Und wir dachten, die geschlossenen Wagons wären besser, aber es hat sich nachher herausgestellt, dass wir noch schlechter daran waren.
David Boder: [In English] Alright, continue.
Jürgen Bassfreund: [In German] Und als wir an diesen Wagons standen, da trieb uns die SS dann wieder in die Wagons hinein, und zwar 120 Menschen in einem Wagon. Also es war eine Unmöglichkeit...
David Boder: In einem geschlossenen Wagon?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In einem geschlossenen Wagon. Die Türen wurden zugemacht, Verpflegung hatten wir nicht mit und nun versuchten wir uns zu setzen. Aber es war nicht möglich. Wenn 80 Leute gesessen haben, konnten die Anderen schon nicht mehr stehen und es waren auch sehr viel Leute dabei, die sehr müde waren. Also es war nicht anders möglich, der Eine ist auf den Anderen drauf gestanden. Wir haben uns auf die Finger getreten und die Leute haben sich natürlich wieder gewehrt und haben geschlagen. Also es brach direkt eine Panik aus. Und es war so schlimm, dass Leute wahnsinnig wurden während der Fahrt, aber während wir gefahren sind, war sonst—unter anderem der erste Tote. Und wir haben nicht gewusst, wo wir die Toten hinlegen sollten; auf der Erde haben sie doch Platz weg genommen, weil sie doch lang gelegen haben. Und dann sind wir auf die Idee gekommen, wir hatten jeder eine Decke mit und da haben wir diesen Toten in diese Decke eingehüllt. Und an diesem Wagon waren zwei Eisenstäbe, da haben wir ihn oben festgeknotet, nicht.
David Boder: Also wie eine Hängematte?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, wie in einer Hängematte. Es war aber...wir haben aber bald eingesehen, dass das nicht geht, denn es wurden immer mehr Tote und durch die Hitze im Wagon fingen die Leichen auch schon zu riechen an. Also wir sind gefahren und damals waren diese Transporte, diese deutschen Truppentransporte, die zurück gingen von der Front—weil doch die Front, hm, zurück ging, weil die Russen doch immer vorwärts gingen, waren die ganzen Geleise verstopft und wir mussten tagelang stehen und erst diese Truppentransporte durch lassen. Nachts haben wir natürlich überhaupt nichts sehen können und wir sind geschlagen worden und getreten worden. Bei mir war es, zum Beispiel, so, dass meine Hosen, meine Häftlingshosen, wie ich getreten wurde, wurden sie plötzlich aufgerissen—der Länge nach—und ich konnte die Hose schon gar nicht mehr tragen und ich war nur noch in Unterhosen. Wir sind so ohne Verpflegung, also ohne einen Tropfen Wasser und ohne ein Stück Brot, dass trotzdem wir geschrieen haben nach Wasser und draußen Schnee lag, hat uns die SS nichts gegeben. Und wir...da waren wahnsinnig viele Tote im Wagon als wir dann fünf Tage gefahren waren, waren wir in Regensburg. Und es war schon Nacht und da hat die SS die Tür aufgemacht und hat gesagt, wenn wir die Toten raus werfen, kriegen wir was zu essen. Und da hab ich selbst mit meinem Freund zusammen 25 Tote aus diesem Wagon raus gezogen und draußen in den Schnee gelegt, net. Und dann haben wir ein Stück Brot bekommen und einen kleinen Becher mit Suppe. Das hat damals dieses Rote Kreuz, die Verpflegungsstelle, also wir mussten vor den Wagons antreten und dann bekam dann jeder das so verabreicht—immer wagonweise.
David Boder: Von wo haben Sie den Becher gehabt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Den Becher, den hat das Rote Kreuz gestellt, das waren solche Pappbecher.
David Boder: Ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Die, die haben wir dann dort bekommen. Und nachdem wir das gegessen hatten, also...
David Boder: War das das deutsche Rote Kreuz?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das war das deutsche Rote Kreuz. Nachdem wir das gegessen hatten, mussten wir wieder in den Wagon zurück—also ich war in Unterhosen und im Schnee. Strümpfe hatte ich schon keine mehr angehabt und ich weiß auch nicht, was die Leute da gesagt haben—die Schwestern—weiß ich auch nicht, jedenfalls wir sind weiter gefahren.
David Boder: Konnten Sie sich keine neue Hose, eine andere Hose schaffen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, das war unmöglich, ich hätte höchstens einem Toten die Hose ausziehen müssen, aber man war so entkräftet von der langen Fahrt und wenn man fünf Tage und fünf Nächte nicht gegessen hat. Ich habe die ganze Zeit während dieser Fahrt gestanden und habe mir nur dadurch das Leben gerettet, dass ich ein Stück Schnur an den Wagon angebunden habe und mich daran festgehalten habe. Also, es war ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Also, ein Freund von mir, der die ganzen Jahre in Auschwitz ausgehalten hat, ist wahnsinnig geworden während der Fahrt. Er wollte mit einem Messer auf mich los gehen und wir haben ihn zu viert oder fünft sogar festhalten müssen, sonst hätte er noch Leute umgebracht. Also, es war direkt eine Panik. Wir hatten Angst vor der Nacht, weil man nachts doch nichts gesehen hat, wenn jemand auf Einem zu kam. Der ganze Wagon war in Aufruhr. Wir hörten später, als wir in Dachau ankamen, dass es in den offenen Wagons ähnlich war. Also, es war wenigstens dort Luft, aber die Leute sind teilweise erfroren und also...Als wir in Dachau ankamen, waren fast mehr Leichen dort als...als Überlebende. Es waren eben die jüngeren Leute, die dies ausgehalten haben. Und in Dachau selbst war ich im Ganzen drei Wochen. Und nachdem ich drei Wochen dort war...also ich wollte noch erzählen, dass in Dachau zu meiner Zeit eine sehr große Flecktyphus-Epidemie war und dass dort ganze Baracken ausgestorben sind. Und morgens auf Leiterwagen wurden die Toten—der Eine mit dem Kopf nach der Seite, der Andere mit den Füßen nach der Seite—auf Wagen geschichtet und wurden dann zur Verbrennung gefahren. Ich weiß heute selbst nicht, wieso wir damals von der Flecktyphus-Epidemie verschont geblieben sind, denn um uns herum, also unsere Baracke im Vordergrund und daneben direkt eine Baracke mit Flecktyphus; also es war furchtbar. Die meisten Leute haben...haben versucht so oft wie möglich sich jeden Tag zu waschen, um dieser Epidemie zu entgehen, denn es waren sehr viel Läuse damals in Dachau. Und dann sind wir nach drei Wochen—nachdem wir vor dem Lagerkommandanten von Dachau vorbei marschieren mussten—hat er entschieden, wer auf Transport geht und wer im Invaliden-Block bleiben muss. Und ich bin damals selbst auf Transport gegangen.
David Boder: Und was war das für ein Transport?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Der Transport war nach einem Lager, Mühldorf hieß es. Mühldorf, das ist ein Ort in der Nähe von Rosenheim. Es ist 78 Kilometer von München und liegt in Oberbayern. Als wir in Mühldorf ankamen, haben wir ein Lager gesehen, wie wir es selbst in Auschwitz nicht gesehen haben. Also es war an und für sich kein Lager, es waren nur runde Papp-Zelte, so wie Finnen-Zelte, wie man sagt, die meisten Blocks waren so halb unterirdisch. Und Wasser gab’s in diesem Lager nur alle vier, fünf Tage. Bewacht waren wir von der SS und bei der Arbeit von der Organisation Todt, das war...das waren diese, diese...
David Boder: Der Organisation Tod?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Wer waren diese?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das waren .auch...also in...brauner Uniform mit Hakenkreuz Binde, net. Und haben Einem vielleicht genau so gut schikaniert wie die SS. Also ein Unterschied bestand da nicht.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie dort gearbeitet?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dort mussten wir Zement tragen. Das war eine Baustelle, dort wollte man einen Flugplatz anlegen. Und an diesem, an diesem Flugplatz mussten...wurden in drei Schichten gearbeitet. Und die Leute, also nachdem die Russen schon solche Gebiete von Deutschland besetzt hatten—also Oberschlesien und so, gab es natürlich noch ein Rationskürzung. Dann bekamen nur acht Mann ein Brot und das war sehr wenig natürlich, da kam ungefähr eine Scheibe Brot am Tag auf einen Mann, nicht.
David Boder: Wo wurde das Brot gebacken?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das Brot wurde in Mühldorf selbst gebacken, teilweise bei Bäckern, aber ich glaube, es war auch eine Lagerbäckerei dort. Und ich erinnere mich, dass bei einem Fliegerangriff dieses, dieses Brotdepot in Brand geraten ist und da haben wir vier Tage überhaupt kein Brot bekommen, sondern jeden Tag drei, vier Pellkartoffel. Da kann ich mich auch noch darauf erinnern. Und dann in Mühldorf selbst waren katastrophale Zustände. Die Leute waren verlaust, man bekam keine Wäsche zum wechseln. Die Leute, die von Warschau schon damals in dieses Lager gekommen sind, hatten schon monatelang überhaupt keine frische Wäsche bekommen. Handtücher gab es nicht, wenn man sich waschen wollte, musste man sich am Hemd abtrocknen. Und es war sehr, sehr schwer sich sauber zu halten, denn durch dieses Zement...dieses Zement-Tragen war man natürlich ganz weiß und es war sehr schwer, weil es doch nur alle vier oder fünf Tage einmal Wasser gab. Also, es brach dort auch in großem Masse Typhus aus, von dem ich auch betroffen wurde und ich bin dann...
David Boder: Flecktyphus oder Magentyphus?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Flecktyphus—von Läusen, von den Kleiderläusen. Und ich hab dann ungefähr vier, fünf Tage dort gelegen mit Flecktyphus, wir haben dort zu zweit in einem Bett gelegen, ein Hemd hatten wir nicht . Wir lagen nackt in den Betten und es war sehr kalt zu der Zeit, aber wir haben doch schon gewusst, dass bald Schluss sein wird, denn man hat schon täglich viele amerikanische Flugzeuge fliegen sehen und man hat schon keine Schüsse mehr gehört von Deutschen, also die, die Abwehr war schon überhaupt nicht mehr in Tätigkeit und wir haben jeden Tag, jede Stunde gewartet, dass bald die Befreiung kommt. Und am 2. Mai war es dann endlich so weit, man hat schon Schießen gehört. Manche Leute haben erzählt, die SS sei schon weg. Ich wusste es natürlich nicht, weil ich dort mit Fieber gelegen hab. Jedenfalls weiß ich, dass am 2. Mai morgens die ersten Amerikaner ins Lager hinein kamen.
David Boder: In welchem Lager war das?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mühldorf am Inn. Und nachdem, nachdem wir zwei Stunden noch im Lager waren, wurden wir bereits in Rote Kreuz-Autos verladen und nach Ampfing gefahren. Das ist ein kleiner Ort neben diesem Lager. Dort wurden wir in Häusern der Organisation Tod untergebracht, da hat man uns ein Lager zurecht gemacht.
David Boder: Ein Lager zurecht gestellt. Und?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und wir wurden sehr gut verpflegt und es war sehr gut.
David Boder: [In English] With exception of a half a sentence, this record is complete—we simply let this spool overrun that time in the Funkenkaserne. Eh, one has to check up whether the next spool has the ending of it—there is a previous spool that has Jürgen Bassfreund’s story. Whether we have gone over to another one, I will have to check. This final remark was made December the 13, 1946 at my home, while analyzing the records. December 13, 1946. It’s a remark made in Chicago, not in Munich.
Herman Barnett: Spool 29—...Spool 139, recording starts in about one minute. Spool 139, recording starts in about one minute. This is Hermann Barnett.
David Boder: Spool 139, continuation of Spool 138 and 137. We have Jürgen Bassfreund continuing his report. Munich, September 20th, 1946. Rather late in the evening at the camp for displaced people...managed by the UNRRA.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Sie hatten Typhus bekommen und Sie wurden vom Roten Kreuz nach der Befreiung nach einem anderen Krankenhaus geschafft?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja. Und dort war die Verpflegung...es war sehr gut. Die Amerikaner haben sich sehr, sehr bemüht um uns. Wir wurden ärztlich sehr gut betreut und die...wir bekamen Blutinjektionen. Ich wog damals 64 Pfund, als ich aus dem Lager heraus kam und wir wurden gleich...wir bekamen Traubenzuckerinjektionen und Vitamintabletten und es wurde sehr gut für uns gesorgt. Wir bekamen sehr gut zu essen. Und ich hab dann nach vierzehn (14) Tagen, als ich aufstand, wieder einen Rückfall bekommen und ich musste mich wieder hinlegen. Aber es war natürlich jetzt etwas ganz Anderes. Während man im Lager überhaupt keine...keine Medikamente oder irgendwelche Abwehrmittel gegen eine Krankheit erhalten hat, war natürlich hier ein Flecktyphus eine ganz andere Sache. Wir wurden...wir bekamen Tabletten und wir wurden täglich drei, vier Mal vom Arzt, hm, besucht und gemessen—das Fieber, die Temperatur wurde gemessen und so war es dann auch kein Wunder, dass wir uns bald wieder erholten. Und eigentlich kann ich sagen, dass von den Leuten, die von den amerikanischen Truppen befreit wurden, wenig noch gestorben sind, nachher. Es sind Einzelfälle gewesen, wo Leute eben schon so schwach waren, dass wirklich keine Hilfe mehr möglich war, aber im Großen und Ganzen sind wir alle wieder gesund geworden und sind dann ungefähr nach dreimonatigem Aufenthalt in diesem Hospital dann entlassen worden.
David Boder: Ich möchte einige nähere Einzelheiten, hm, bei der Beschreibung von den Hospital-Bedingungen im Lager haben, bevor die Amerikaner rein kamen. Sie hatten Typhus gehabt, nicht wahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Beschreiben Sie das Zimmer, wo Sie gelegen sind, und so weiter.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also wir lagen in einem runden Zelt und in diesem Zelt waren drei Betten über einander. Wir lagen zu zweit im Bett, es war unangenehm, zum Beispiel, wenn jemand verstorben war, wollte der Blockälteste von diesem Block natürlich noch die Brotportion und die Suppe und was eben war, wollte er noch haben und deshalb musste der, durfte der Tote erst einen Tag später als tot gemeldet werden, damit die Verpflegung noch eingetroffen ist für ihn. Und da mussten wir eben so lange mit diesem Toten zusammen noch im Bett liegen. Und es...
David Boder: Sie sagten „wir”. Ist es Ihnen passiert?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, mir selbst ist es einmal passiert, dass ich mit einem toten Franzosen einen Tag liegen musste noch. Und zwar starb er damals an Bauchtyphus, also an Durchfall und ich musste einen Tag noch mit ihm zusammen noch liegen und dann erst ist er...
David Boder: In welcher Etage waren Sie?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In der ersten Etage.
David Boder: Unten? Ganz oben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, in der ersten Etage, erst war das Unterbett und im Mittelbett war ich.
David Boder: Ach so, das untere Bett hat einfach Unterbett gehießen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das Unterbett, das Eine, das Mittelbett und dann war das Oberbett noch.
David Boder: Aha, ah so! Und Sie waren im Mittelbett?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich war im Mittelbett gelegen, ja. Und es war insofern, also es war grauenvoll nachts, erstmals waren die Toten ganz abgezehrt und sahen furchtbar aus. Dann haben Sie meistens...noch unter sich gemacht im letzten Moment. Also es war ein sehr unästhetisches. . . unästhetische Sache. Und ich hab da, hm, im Lager selbst oft solche Fälle gesehen, also in dem Krankenrevier, dass, zum Beispiel, Leute, die an einem Phlegmon, einer Eiterung gestorben sind, das...da war das ganze Bett voller Eiter, nicht, und da war jemand, der vielleicht weniger krank war, der vielleicht nur eine kleine Wunde hatte und der hat sich dann wieder infiziert daran und so. Und wie es überhaupt bei uns im Lager so war, wenn wirklich schon einmal ein Arzt morgens Visite machte, der hatte überhaupt keine Hilfsmittel weiter, mit einer Schere wurden zum Beispiel, die größten Eiter...Eitergeschwulste aufgeschnitten und mit derselben Schere wurde dann am Nächsten, der vielleicht weniger hatte, der vielleicht nur eine geringe Verletzung hatte, wurde dann mit derselben Schere—ohne, dass die vorher irgendwie gereinigt wurde oder was—wurde dann, hm, der Andere mit behandelt. Und Verbandsstoff gab es ja insofern überhaupt nicht; es gab ganz wenig und das war alles Papierverbandsstoff, also wenn der Verband wirklich schon einmal eine Stunde drauf war, dann war das schon sehr viel, weil das doch immer wieder gerutscht ist und so. Und Tabletten gab’s überhaupt nicht in der letzten Zeit mehr...
David Boder: Was für Tabletten?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also zum Beispiel, gegen Fieber—Aspirin oder solche Sachen. Das gab’s zum Schluss überhaupt nicht mehr und der Zustand war eben—je, je mehr, also je mehr wir abgeschnitten waren, umso katastrophaler war der Zustand, nicht. Nachher war schon alles ein Drunter und Drüber im Lager. Man hat schon überhaupt keine Verpflegung mehr gehabt. Die SS haben geschaut, dass sie weg kamen bevor die Amerikaner kamen und die stellten dann einfach deutsche Polizei oben auf die Wachtürme und da war überhaupt...da waren Häftlinge, die haben wieder das, hm, das Proviantlager ganz ausgeplündert...
David Boder: Wie die, wie die Deutschen weggingen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, wie die SS wegging.
David Boder: Und die Amerikaner noch nicht da waren.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und die Amerikaner noch nicht da waren.
David Boder: Und mit dem Ausgeplünderten, was wollen sie damit machen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, sie haben’s gegessen diese Vorräte, was noch da war. Weil die Leute waren so ausgehungert, ein Stück Brot war dort eine große Kostbarkeit, net. Das ist doch selbstverständlich, wenn Leute so ausgehungert sind, dass sie gesehen haben...die Kranken, die mussten eben, die konnten nicht aufstehen und wir konnten es uns nicht zumuten, während die Anderen, die noch auf waren—also nicht krank waren—konnten sich wenigstens aus dem Vorratslager Wurst oder was drin war holen, net.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wie lange hat diese Zwischenzeit gedauert, wo die SS weg waren und die Amerikaner noch nicht da waren?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, also das kann ich nicht genau sagen, weil ich damals sehr im Fieber gelegen hab. Meiner Schätzung waren es ungefähr ein bis zwei Tage, der ganze Zustand.
David Boder: Ja. Und waren unterdessen ein Arzt dort geblieben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ein...es waren jüdische Ärzte, also Häftlingsärzte, wie man sagte, die waren schon dort. Weil alles was noch gehen konnte, wollten die Nazis wieder weiter auf Transport schicken und nicht den Amerikanern ausliefern. Ich habe also jetzt in der Funkkaserne mit einem Freund von mir gesprochen, den ich zufällig dort traf, und er erzählte mir, dass sie noch sehr viel mitmachen mussten. Sie wurden einwagoniert, dann sagte die SS, sie können weglaufen, weil die Amerikaner schon da waren. Und als sie mitten im Lauf waren, fing hinter ihnen eine Schießerei an und man hat sie wieder eingefangen teilweise und hat die Leute wieder in Wagons und hat sie wieder weiter geschoben. Und dann ist die SS weg gelaufen und dann haben die Amerikaner nicht gewusst, was in den Wagons drin war.. Und es ist noch ein Tieffliegerangriff gewesen, da sind noch Häftlinge ums Leben gekommen und. . . Also es muss ein katastrophaler Zustand gewesen sein. Zuerst hieß es...zuerst hieß es, dass die Kranken erschossen würden, aber...es war wohl...nachher hatte der Lagerkommandant doch Angst, weil zu so vorgerückter Stunde wollte er es vielleicht nichts mehr machen und wir sind einfach so liegen geblieben.
David Boder: Hm, hm. Also nun und, so sind Sie nachher—nach Ihrem Rückfall—im amerikanischen Hospital gewesen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann haben Sie sich drei Monate erholt und was ist dann passiert?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nachdem ich mich dort nach drei Monaten erholt hatte, mussten wir also fort von diesem Lager...und wir sind dann nach, nach, hm, München gekommen und von München aus versuchten wir dann nach Hause zu fahren. Wir hatten uns erst von der Militärregierung Pässe besorgt; ich habe, zum Beispiel, zuletzt in Berlin gewohnt und ich wollte nach Berlin fahren, und sehen, was meine Eltern, ob meine, ob meine Mutter noch lebt. Und hab, hm,...bin aber dann nicht gefahren, weil es doch sehr schwierig war und die Transportverbindungen war doch noch nicht so gut. Also ich bin in Bayern geblieben da, damals.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mir mal, wieviel wissen Sie und was wissen Sie von Ihrer Mutter?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich weiß eigentlich von meiner Mutter gar nichts. Ich weiß so viel, dass meine Mutter nicht mehr aus dem Lager zurück gekommen ist.
David Boder: Wissen Sie, dass sie wegtransportiert wurde?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, das weiß ich.
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen das gesagt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das erzählte mir ein, ein jüdisches Mädel, also die eine christliche Mutter hatte, schon in dem Sammellager war, meine Mutter auch noch gesehen hatte. Und dann wieder frei kam, weil sie eine christliche Mutter hatte, und nicht als Volljüdin gegolten hat und daher von dem Transport fernbleiben sollte.
David Boder: Aha. Und, hm, Sie haben es probiert nach Berlin zu schreiben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Oder verschiedenen Stellen sich zu verbinden?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja, natürlich, ich hab mich selbstverständlich mit der jüdischen Gemeinde in Berlin in Verbindung gesetzt, zumal dort der Leiter dieser Gemeinde ein Häftling war, der mit mir zusammen im Lager war. Und ich hab den Bescheid bekommen, dass meine Mutter nicht dort eingetroffen ist und auch nicht registriert ist. Und es ist wahrscheinlich anzunehmen, dass sie nicht mehr lebt. Denn ich nehme bestimmt an, wenn meine Mutter noch leben würde, dass sie doch jeden Hebel in Bewegung gesetzt hätte, um mich zu finden. Außerdem hätte bestimmt meine Schwester in England doch irgendwie eine Nachricht bekommen.
David Boder: Korrespondieren Sie mit Ihrer Schwester?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich korres...ich korrespondiere mit meiner Schwester und meine Schwester hat mir geschrieben—sie musste selbstverständlich zuerst meine Adresse nicht und es hat lange gedauert, bis wir wieder Verbindung bekamen.
David Boder: Haben Sie Ihre Schwesters Adresse gewusst?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich habe die alte Adresse meiner Schwester gewusst, aber es hat sich insofern verändert, dass meine Schwester nachher in die, in die englische Armee eingetreten ist und nach London gekommen ist und die Briefe, die ich nach Newcastle geschrieben habe, sind zurück gekommen. Ich lernte aber dann im Schutt einen amerikanischen Soldaten kennen, der selbst in Newcastle Verwandte hat und der hat dann die Verbindung hergestellt und hat dann erfahren, dass meine Schwester gar nicht mehr dort ist, sondern in London.
David Boder: Und dann haben Sie Ihre Schwester in London gefunden?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Dann habe ich meine Schwester in London gefunden, ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie sie gesehen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, sehen konnte ich sie doch nicht.
David Boder: Sie konnten nicht nach London rüber fahren?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein.
David Boder: Und Sie fahren jetzt weg, ohne Ihre Schwester gesehen zu haben?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ich fahre jetzt nach Amerika und zwar hat auch meine Schwester mir geschrieben, dass sie es besser findet, wenn ich nach Amerika fahre, denn sie schreibt, dass sie selbst es sehr schwer hat, trotzdem sie jetzt eingebürgert worden ist. Aber dass es sehr schwer ist, erstens einmal die Auswanderungsmöglichkeiten sind nicht so gut und es ist schwerer nach England zu kommen, als nach den Vereinigten Staaten.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie...nun, also da haben Sie sich mit Ihrer Schwester in Verbindung gesetzt. Also, wie sind Sie, wo sind Sie gewesen zwischen dieser Entlassung vom Hospital und das Ihre Ankunft hier in diesem UNRRA, hm, Verteil...Verteilungslager oder Transitlager?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Also ich bin gleich nachdem nach Fürth gefahren. In Fürth hatte ich eine Tante, die Lehrerin war und ich glaubte, dass sie noch leben würde. Aber ich habe dann von Augenzeugen gehört, dass sie in Riga erschossen worden ist.
David Boder: In Riga?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Wie ist Ihre Tante nach Riga gekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Tante ist schon im Jahre ’41 nach Riga gekommen. Und zwar war das damals auch einer dieser Evakuierungstransporte. Und in Riga hat man dann nach kurzer Zeit Leute zum Erschießen genommen, also meistens ältere Personen und so und da war meine Tante auch darunter, wie mir gesagt worden ist. Also ich habe meine Tante nicht getroffen und ich wollte gerne in der amerikanischen Besatzungszone bleiben. Also bin ich in Fürth geblieben. Ich habe dort durch die jüdische Gemeinde ein Zimmer bekommen und ich hab dort an meine Verwandten nach Amerika geschrieben und habe wieder die Verbindung aufgenommen. Und hatte dann das Glück, dass ich von meinem Onkel ein Affidavit bekam und heute hier in der Funkkaserne sein kann und auf den Abtransport warten kann. Und ich habe auch...in der Zwischenzeit, ich habe mir gedacht, dass es doch gut ist, wenn man jetzt etwas lernt, weil doch die ganzen Jahre so, so wechselvoll waren und man kam nie dazu richtig sich einer Sache zu widmen. Und ich bin in ein Kino als Vorführer gegangen.
David Boder: Was für ein Kino?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In ein Kino für Zivilpersonen, dass einem Juden gehörte, der auch im KZ war.
David Boder: Wo?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Fürth selber. Und habe dort gelernt und habe geglaubt, dass es besser ist selbstverständlich, wenn man doch irgendetwas kann und dass man nachher nicht so abhängig ist von seinen Verwandten, dass man seinen Lebensunterhalt—wenn es auch primitiv ist—doch immerhin selbst fristen kann.
David Boder: Nun und sagen Sie mal, wie haben Sie die Adressen Ihrer Verwandten gefunden? Haben Sie die immer gewusst?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, selbstverständlich sind sie mir entfallen, aber meine Schwester hat sie mir von England aus geschrieben und von dort aus habe ich dann selbst hin geschrieben. Außerdem sagte mir auch meine Schwester die Adresse einer früheren Freundin von ihr, die schon im Jahre ’36 oder ’37 nach den Staaten ausgewandert ist und die in Frankfurt bei der Information Control Division als, hm, als Bürokraft tätig ist und sie hat dann direkt ihre Schwester, die auch hier bei der Besatzungsarmee war—ist gleich nachdem sie wieder zurück war zu meinen Verwandten gegangen und hat meine Lage geschildert und hat...
David Boder: Als sie wieder in Amerika war?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja und hat auch, glaube ich, die nötigen Schritte unternommen, jedenfalls habe ich danach, kurz nachdem sie dort war von Frankfurt von der HIAS diese Nachricht bekommen,...
David Boder: Von der HIAS haben Sie diese Nachricht bekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: . . . dass ich, dass ich ein Affidavit habe und ich hab dann noch, ich hab dann noch eine CIC-Prüfung...da habe ich noch vier oder fünf Wochen gewartet und bekam dann die Einberufung in die Funkkaserne.
David Boder: Aha. Wer hat Sie in die Funkenkaserne einberufen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das UNRRA-Headquarter.
David Boder: Die UNRRA, wie haben die das erfahren, dass Sie wegfahren—nach Amerika fahren?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, nachdem, ich glaube, der Weg ist so: nachdem ich...die CIC eine Prüfung unternommen hat...
David Boder: Was ist CIC?
Jürgen Bassfreund: CIC ist das Counter Intelligence Corps. Und man wird dann geprüft und man muss einen Fragebogen, ob man politisch einwandfrei ist und was da alles drum und dran hängt mit einer Auswanderung. Das wird dann geprüft und wird dann zum Konsulat geschickt und danach wird eben, wird vom Konsulat aus, also die Funkkaserne benachrichtigt, dass man soweit ist, um hier einberufen zu werden, um...
David Boder: Also Sie wurden von Fürth einberufen, nicht wahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Von Fürth aus, ja.
David Boder: Wie weit ist Fürth von hier?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Fürth ist von hier...also genau die Kilometer weiß ich nicht, jedenfalls mit der Bahn zu fahren ungefähr drei Stunden.
David Boder: Und wer hat Ihnen die Passage bezahlt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Wie—die Passage von...>
David Boder: Das Billet—wer hat das bezahlt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nach Amerika?
David Boder: Nein, nein, nein von Fürth nach Frankfurt—nach München.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das hab ich doch von dem, was ich im Kino verdient habe, selbst...
David Boder: Haben Sie selbst bezahlt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Habe ich selber bezahlt.
David Boder: So. Und Sie haben einen Onkel in Atlanta, nicht wahr?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Hm, was tut der dort?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Mein Onkel hat dort eine Gärtnerei und ein Blumengeschäft.
David Boder: Eine Gärtnerei und ein Blumengeschäft?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Und Sie fahren direkt zu ihm?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, also ich will erst nochmal in New York zu meinem Onkel und meinen Vetter besuchen
David Boder: Was machen sie dort?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Sie meinen mein Vetter arbeitet bei der Jewish Telegraph Agency.
David Boder: Oh, ja.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und ist schon, glaube ich, zehn Jahre dort beschäftigt.
David Boder: Ja und?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Und es ist doch selbstverständlich, wenn ich in New York ankomme, dass ich ihn auch dort besuchen will.
David Boder: Ja. Können Sie schon ein bisserl englisch?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich hab ein bisschen gelernt schon in der ganzen Zeit. Wir haben Kurse gehabt und es waren teilweise Amerikaner dort, die sich sehr bemüht haben.
David Boder: Wo?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Fürth—war unter anderen ein Lehrer, der dort im Courthouse in Nürnberg—das ist Fürth und Nürnberg, das ist eine Doppelstadt, nicht, der hat abends immer sich noch Zeit genommen, um uns Englisch Unterricht zu geben und wir haben eigentlich sehr schön schon dort gelernt. Es ist natürlich noch nicht sehr viel, aber man hat immerhin...die Grundbegriffe kennen wirschon und es ist doch immerhin schon besser, als wenn man so...
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal...
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja?
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, sind Sie nach Ihrer Befreiung mit Stockdeutschen zusammen gekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich bin mit Christen auch zusammen gekommen, selbstverständlich, und zwar hab ich, muss ich sagen, dass bei diesen Leuten also teilweise das Verständnis für unsere Lage vollkommen fehlt. Also es gibt manche Leute, wenn man da gesagt hat, man kommt aus dem KZ, da haben sie, zum Beispiel, gesagt: ‚Ja, meine Angehörigen sind durch Bomben umgekommen, das ist genau so schlimm.’ Aber es gab einen Teil wieder, die wollten sich da völlig abwenden, die wussten davon nichts, was in den Konzentrationslagern passiert und, hm, wenn sie das gewusst hätten und das Volk, da hätten sie gar nichts sagen dürfen, denn sie waren ängstlich, dass sie selbst ins Lager kommen und so. Es ist verschieden die Auffassung. Also ich muss sagen eigentlich ein Eingeständnis von Seiten der Deutschen, dass man sagen kann, dass sie sagen ‚ja, es war falsch’ oder ‚es war nicht richtig, was wir gemacht haben’, hat man selten gehört.
David Boder: Ja. Nun sagen Sie, wie verstehen Sie das mit guter Einsicht, was erwarten eigentlich die Deutschen in der Zukunft? Was ist, hm, was ist die Auffassung der Deutschen jetzt von der ganzen Situation?
Jürgen Bassfreund: JJa, also es ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Die Deutschen glauben nun natürlich, die Amerikaner müssen...werden sie wieder herauf heben. Also sie glauben, zum Beispiel, habe ich auch vielfach schon die Meinung gehört: ‚Sage, Du bist Jude, Du gehst heute nach Amerika, Du wirst sehen, es werden Juden aus Amerika noch einmal hierher kommen, damit der Handel wieder auflebt.’ Und solche kindischen und naiven Ansichten haben ein großer Teil dieser Leute. Und sie können auch nicht verstehen, dass uns zum Beispiel eigentlich Deutschland gar nichts bedeutet, außer dass wir dort geboren sind und so. Es ist doch selbstverständlich—ein Land, wo man alles, was man besessen hat, die Eltern vor allen Dingen, ein Wert, der doch gar nicht zu ersetzen ist, wenn Einem das genommen worden ist, dann kann man überhaupt keine Gefühle mehr haben für, für so ein Land.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir—wie weit Sie es wissen—hm, sind welche deutschen Juden also zurückgekommen oder haben sich welche deutschen Juden angefangen, hier nieder zu lassen, um wieder zu arbeiten und wieder zu ihrem Gewerbe zurück zu gehen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, also ich muss sagen, es sind ganz, ganz wenige darunter, die wirklich wieder Geschäfte aufgemacht haben oder, oder Kinos aufgemacht haben. Aber der Prozentsatz ist so gering und, hm, ich glaube trotzdem, die meisten, die ich gesprochen habe, sagen, sie machen es nur vorübergehend, um sich hier noch unterhalten zu können, wollen aber auch versuchen, möglichst bald von hier fort zu kommen.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, zum Beispiel, der Mann, wo sie im Kino gearbeitet haben, wo war er während des Krieges?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Er war auch im Konzentrationslager.
David Boder: Und wer hat im Kino gehabt?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Bitte?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Das Kino hat einem ehemaligen Nationalsozialisten gehört, dem, dem wurde es abgenommen. Und er hat daraufhin—auf Grund dessen, dass er so lange im Konzentrationslager war, hat er das Kino von der Militärregierung vom Nachrichtenkontrolloffizier, also, bekommen.
David Boder: Von welchem Kontrolloffizier?
Jürgen Bassfreund: In Nürnberg—vom Nachrichtenverbindungsoffizier.
David Boder: Was heißt das Nachrichten?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nachrichtenverbindungsoffizier.
David Boder: Ah, Nachrichtenverbindungsoffizier. Ah, hat er das Kino zurückbekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, es hat ihm vorher nicht gehört. Er hat vorher in Breslau gewohnt und ist dann eben nachher nach Bayern gekommen und hat das Kino bekommen dort.
David Boder: Oh, es war nicht sein Kino.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, es war nicht sein Kino.
David Boder: Also wieso hat er das Kino bekommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, er hat es vielleicht...
David Boder: Also das Kino wurde nie von ihm weg genommen?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, es wurde nicht von ihm weg genommen.
David Boder: Also sie haben ihm einfach das Kino gegeben, dass er anfangen kann...
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, aber es ist nicht nur, dass man es einem Juden gibt. Man gibt es Christen, zum Beispiel auch. Ich kenne in Fürth, zum Beispiel, eine Dame, die bei der...die lange in Amerika war und eine Zeit lang bei der Militärregierung als Dolmetscher gearbeitet hat...
David Boder: Bei den amerikanische Militärregierung, nicht?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, ja. Und sie hat auch ein Kino bekommen, wenigstens so als Treuhänderin, wie man so sagt.
David Boder: Aha, als Verwalterin.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, als Verwalterin.
David Boder: Ist sie eine Amerikanerin oder eine Deutsche?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, sie ist eine Deutsche.
David Boder: Aha. Nun und wie kriegen die anderen ihre Geschäfte zurück? Haben andere Juden angefangen zu praktizieren, welche Advokaten, welche Ärzte?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, soweit ich im Bilde bin, also ich...ich weiß keinen zu nennen. Es ist möglich, dass vielleicht in München oder so etwas existiert, aber bei uns war es nicht der Fall.
David Boder: Leben die jüdischen Gemeinden wieder auf, zum Beispiel, in Fürth hat man die Synagoge eröffnet?
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, in Fürth hat man eine Synagoge, da hat man die Synagoge wieder eröffnet und zwar war auch wesentlich daran beteiligt die amerikanischen Chaplins, diese Armee-Rabbiner haben sehr viel dazu beigetragen durch Geldspenden. Und sie haben sich sehr darum bemüht, sie haben dafür gesorgt, dass hebräische Bücher wieder kamen, dass wieder Tora-Rollen in die Synagogen kamen und so.
David Boder: Nun, Sie sind ja also schon Amerikaner!
Jürgen Bassfreund: Nein, leider noch nicht.
David Boder: Na ja, Sie sind schon drüben. Ich will Ihnen sagen, einen guten Rat: Es soll Ihnen keiner einreden, dass die Bildung in Amerika sehr kostlich ist. Es gibt kostliche Schulen, es gibt mittelmäßige Schulen, es gibt freie Schulen, es gibt Korrespondenzkurse. Junge Leute studieren, ältere Leute studieren. Sie werden schon den richtigen Weg finden. Es würde vielleicht gut für Sie sein, dass Sie in Amerika, nachdem Sie sich ausgeruht haben und ein bisschen sich umgesehen haben, dass Sie zu einer Stelle hingehen, wo man Berufsberatung gibt.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja.
David Boder: Psychologische und gewerbliche Berufsberatung. Und sie können dann vielleicht etwas für Sie finden, dass Sie am leichtesten lernen sollen.
David Boder: Da gibt es solche und die ORT hat auch angefangen in Amerika und Ihre Verwandten wahrscheinlich werden auch Ihnen Hilfe geben und wenn Sie fleißig sind und sich an das Leben dort gewöhnen, dann wird es Ihnen schon gut gehen. Also, danke sehr Herr Jürgen, und sie werden wahrscheinlich in Amerika bevor mich, hm, bevor ich hinkomme, sein. Und, hm, ich werde Ihnen meine Adresse geben. Sie können mir mal schreiben, wie es Ihnen geht.
Jürgen Bassfreund: Ja, vor allen Dingen danke ich Ihnen dafür, dass Sie mir Gelegenheit gegeben haben, hier einmal über diese ganzen Erlebnisse aus dem Lager zu sprechen und damit die Leute, damit man ihnen man mal ein Bild geben kann, von dem was wirklich geschehen ist, und das, was ich gesagt hab, sind nur einzelne Fälle und es ist nicht übertrieben, das kann ich mit gutem Gewissen sagen. Im Gegenteil man kann es nicht so schildern, wie es wirklich gewesen ist.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Jürgen Bassfreund, which starts on Spool 137, was interrupted somehow, and completes here twenty minutes of Spool 139. Munich, the 20th of September 1946—in late in the evening at the displaced persons camp, where about counted five thousand people are...live as transients and are expecting transportation to a list of countries that covers practically the whole geography. Hm, only tonight, coming in I saw a group of people waiting at the gate, kind of a group of inter-departmental football, where a organization knowing that the camp is totally overfilled and that there is a menace of possible “revolt” of the...—”revolt” in quotation marks of course—of the inhabitants. New crowds are coming in, the so-called infiltrees; people are now running away from Poland or from other zones coming to the blessed American zone. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: Chicago, November 1st, 1949. This is a duplicated spool for the Library of the Public Health Service. The spool is cut here because it concludes the study of Jürgen Bassfreund, and begins the new interview with Captain Zeplit, which we shall rewind on a new spool, number 9-139B. David P. Boder.